j'ouvre notre second débat tout de suite
vous le savez si vous êtes fidèle à Sens
public on choisit souvent de le décaler
volontairement de l'actualité du jour de
prendre du recul sur les événements pour
mieux comprendre les crises que nous
traversons ce soir c'est le mot autorité
que nous allons analyser après les
émeutes de juin de nombreuses
personnalités politiques appellent un
retour de l'autorité c'est donc l'un des
mots de cette rentrée Jérôme Rabier
c'est la réponse aux émeuts qui ont
touché la France fin juin début juillet
pour l'instant dans les discours
Emmanuel Macron a lancé le mouvement
quand il a pris la parole au cœur de
l'été ce qu'il faudrait au pays c'est le
retour de l'autorité la leçon que j'en
tire c'est un l'ordre l'ordre l'ordre la
deuxième c'est que notre pays a besoin
d'un retour de l'autorité à chaque
niveau et d'abord dans la famille c'est
l'autorité à l'école autorité des
savoirs fondamentaux et des maîtres
c'est l'autorité des élus de nos forces
de sécurité ce marqueur ne vient pas de
nulle part droite et extrême droite
dénonce depuis longtemps le recul de
l'autorité regrettant un temps où elle
était naturelle le patron des
républicains Éric Ciotti en appelle donc
aux parents faute de quoi il serait
responsable
leurs enfants le respect de la règle et
de l'autorité nous devons rebâtir une
société de droits et de voir Marine Le
Pen elle aussi voit un marqueur du
déclin de la France lorsque finalement
les jeunes méprisent les lois parce
qu'il ne reconnaissent plus au-dessus de
l'autorité de rien et de personnes alors
c'est là en toute beauté en toute
jeunesse le début de la tyrannie rentrée
des classes oblige le nouveau ministre
de l'éducation nationale a été un des
premiers à être chargé de décliner
l'autorité dès sa prise de fonction il
avait annoncé la couleur en ces temps
troublé et après ce que le pays a
traversé au début du mois de juillet il
faut en revenir à des choses simples le
respect du professeur et de son autorité
chacun y va depuis de son commentaire
dans sa tournée des librairies et des
médias l'ancien président Nicolas
Sarkozy regrette aussi une perte de
repères la France traverse une crise
d'autorité une société ne peut pas vivre
sans autorité sans verticalité sans
leader en cette rentrée le gouvernement
doit décliner secret d’eau et le chef de
l'État l'incarné mais attention
l'autorité peut aussi être remise en
cause comme l'ont montré les sifflets
qui ont retenti lors de la prise de
parole d'Emmanuel Macron au Stade de
France pour l'ouverture de la Coupe du
monde de rugby
la France en panne d'autorité c'est le
thème de notre débat j'accueil Pascal
Bruckner bonsoir bienvenue écrivain
philosophe auteur de ce livre le sacre
des pantoufles aux éditions Grasset
Yanis roder bonsoir bonsoir venu à vous
aussi directeur de l'Observatoire à de
l'éducation à la Fondation Jean Jaurès
membre du conseil des sages de la
laïcité vous êtes professeur agrégé
d'histoire-géo depuis 22 ans
principalement en réseau d'éducation
prioritaire et puis vous publiez la
jeunesse française l'école et la
République aux éditions de
l'Observatoire Élise appelle ski et
rester à mes côtés
éditorialise pour sens publique alors
l'autorité Pascal Bruckner j'ai
l'impression que ça fait quelques
décennies que elle est mise en elle est
mise en péril si je me souviens de mes
cours de philo un Aaren t'en parlais
déjà dans les années 60 est-ce que c'est
l'aboutissement d'une lampe dérive à
laquelle on assiste d'après vous mais
l'autorité c'est ce qui est perdu depuis
toujours on voit déjà ça chez Platon où
il déplore dans la République
le renversement des valeurs les parents
obéissent aux enfants les élèves sont
devenus les maîtres des maîtres et même
les animaux
dictent leurs conditions aux hommes et
donc la grande question politique c'est
comment fonder une cité sur une autorité
incontestable et donc ça a été ça a été
vrai pour les Grecs pour les Romains qui
eux ont fondé sur les les pères de la
des pères de l'Empire et de la
République et évidemment en démocratie
le problème de l'autorité est d'autant
plus fort que nous sommes des sociétés
égalitaires et donc
l'autorité implique une hiérarchie et au
moins la hiérarchie de la tradition et
c'est là nous la reconnaissons pas et
donc nous avons beaucoup de mal à obéir
à des gens dont nous nous disons
qu'après tout ils sont comme nous et qui
n'ont aucun titre à nous donner des
ordres et donc la une des grandes
questions de la des sociétés
démocratiques c'est l'obéissance
effectivement à l'école c'est le respect
c'est-à-dire comment respecter ça veut
dire tenir à distance être tenu à
distance et tenir à distance
et il a et donc l'autorité est un thème
récurrent moi je l'entends depuis
j'allais dire depuis que je suis né mais
j'exagère un peu mais depuis 68 qui est
une révolution
anti-autoritaire effectivement c'est
c'est un tam-tam qui résonne à nos
oreilles tous les jours chlorure est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord pour dire qu'il y
a quand même une crise de l'autorité en
France en ce moment particulier
j'ai l'impression que cette espèce de
facilité de langage que l'on retrouve
surtout beaucoup à droite et à l'extrême
droite dans la bouche de l'ancien
président Nicolas Sarkozy qui par
ailleurs nous dispense sur les plateaux
ces dernières semaines des leçons pour
russe et climato-sceptiques je ne sais
pas vraiment ce que ça veut dire j'ai
plutôt l'impression que ça renvoie une
sorte quand on dit oui on a une crise
d'autorité il faut de l'autorité etc
l'autorité très bien
mais dans la bouche de ces personnes
politiques là ça renvoie une sorte
d'idéalisation d'un passé fantasmé du
temps où le professeur pouvait taper sur
le doigt de l'élève avec les ou du temps
ou le mari pouvait tabasser sa femme en
silence dans sa maison ce passé-là on en
veut plus il ne s'agit pas de revenir à
cela et puis derrière cette espèce de
retourner à ce point en arrière sans
restaurer un peu l'autorité Nicolas
Sarkozy c'est-à-dire quand il dit il
faut plus d'autorité j'ai aussi
l'impression d'une forme de pensée
magique ça veut dire quoi en fait plus
d'autorité ça renvoie à quoi précisément
pour quel but par exemple si on suit la
stratégie qui a été celle du président
Macron d'appliquer plus d'autorité et de
verticalité dans son exercice du pouvoir
de l'État je ne suis pas sûr que les
résultats étaient très probants le fait
de se passer des corps intermédiaires
etc et puis j'observe aussi enfin que
cette demande d'autorité elle est
souvent agiométrie variable c'est-à-dire
qu'on demande de l'autorité face aux
jeunes des quartiers populaires ou même
aux demandeurs d'emploi des personnes
qui sont au RSA en vie il faut être
autoritaire avec eux comme ça il
retourner même s'ils étaient satisfaits
de leur propre situation mais nous ne
faisons pas preuve d'autorité vis-à-vis
des multinationales qui évitent l'impôt
vis-à-vis des industries de
l'agroalimentaire qui aujourd'hui à
travers leur profit alimentent
l'inflation sur le dos des Français nous
ne faisons pas preuve d'autorité
vis-à-vis de Total qui investit dans les
nouveaux projets fossiles et ce qui
m'empêche notre futur mais si vous
voulez donc cette demande d'autorité
elle est à géométrie varie vos arguments
que Yanis Robert il y a je reprends pas
la partie effectivement qui est
intéressante un politique le deux poids
de mesure dont vous parlez mais si on
questionne des figures d'autorité alors
peut-être qu'elles sont traditionnelles
mais à quel point les figures d'autorité
pour vous sont
remises en cause du du parent au chef de
l'État en passant par le scientifique
l'élu évidemment les Luc local le maire
et c'était le professeur
et je m'adresse à un professeur est-ce
que c'est généralisé une certaine façon
c'est difficile c'est difficile de
répondre à votre question moi j'ai pas
une vision globale de de la situation
pour cette question
en ce qui concerne notre pays ce que je
peux me raconter sur le terrain c'est
qu'effectivement il y a comme une sorte
de relativisation de la figure
d'autorité celle notamment que vous
venez de de citer et avec cette idée si
vous voulez que
finalement on a enfin on a on sait et
qu'on n'a pas besoin on n'aurait pas
nécessairement besoin d'aller vers vers
ce qui nous ce qui nous permettrait
vraiment de savoir ce qui nous
permettrait vraiment de construire
quelque chose donc on est on est si vous
voulez dans une situation moi je le vois
avec une partie de des jeunes que j'ai
en face de moi une situation où
finalement là par exemple si on prend la
figure d'autorité du professeur que vous
avez cité
voilà on est dans une situation où on
pense savoir et donc si on sait on n'a
pas besoin du professeur voyez est-ce
que tu en sais vraiment plus que moi
quoi c'est un peu la question
sous-jacente c'est tu d'ailleurs
peut-être vous comme oui vous quand même
parce que le professeur on essaye quand
même de garder ce vouvoiement mais mais
oui mais en réalité vous avez vous avez
des prescripteurs de savoir ou plutôt
l'illusion n'a prescrime prescription de
sa voix aujourd'hui notamment par
Internet les réseaux sociaux etc qui qui
font que la figure d'autorité de
l'enseignant qui qui repose d'abord sur
sa maîtrise de la maîtrise de sa science
et ben finalement n'est plus n'est plus
aussi importante qu'avant puisque le
savoir sans savoir est relativiser par
un accès à ce qu'on pense être un autre
savoir Émilie moi j'ai un peu une autre
façon d'interpréter cette espèce de
d'envie des jeunes de ne pas respecter
l'autorité c'est que la société elle
change beaucoup on s'émancie beaucoup en
tant qu'être humain on essaie de trouver
du sens de travail on fait plus voilà
c'est plus le labeur pour rien on voit
très bien qu'en ce moment les jeunes il
y a d'autres velléités et puis
globalement même les moins jeunes on a
une évolution et du coup ce qu'on attend
c'est plus une autorité avec que des
ordres parce que pour moi l'autorité
c'est pas seulement des ordres c'est un
cadre c'est un cadre mais est-ce qu'on
peut faire société sans un minimum de
cadre et d'autorités avec ça c'est un
cadre avec des valeurs mais les jeunes
ils sont émancipés et ils ont aussi une
exigence et là j'entends aussi il faut
faire le ménage des bons parents par
exemple qui qui demandent quelque chose
aux enfants il faut pas ils peuvent pas
leur dire de fumer s'il fume même mais
c'est un petit peu pareil pour les
responsables politiques les jeunes ont
une exigence même les jeunes ne
population globale une exigence pour que
ces valeurs soient partagées au plus
haut et pour que ce cadre puisse être
imposé c'est d'exemplarité de ceux qui
veulent imposer le cadre exemplarité et
puis plus partager un cadre et des
valeurs et pas des ordres à la baguette
on peut plus on peut plus être dans
cette société là je voudrais rebondir ce
que vous dites parce que vous visez
juste il y a une différence entre
l'autorité le fait de donner un cadre
d'avoir des règles évidemment que toute
société est fondée sur un cadre des
règles et quand on est socialiste comme
moi on y croit profondément on croit
qu'il n'y a pas de liberté en dehors de
la société et des règles auxquelles
vous avez parfois l'impression je vous
donnerai pas le faire après que c'est
que ces règles mais vous pourrez aller
au bout de la démonstration et pas de
souci que c'est ce cadre elles sont ce
cadre il est il n'existe pas forcément
et qui vous avez pas tous les jeunes
évidemment certains jeunes qui voilà qui
l'ont pas ce cadre en quelques mots pour
permettre
il y a des jeunes qui n'ont pas le cadre
et qui ne reconnaissent pas
l'autorité de la loi en fait c'est à
dire que à partir du moment où il
considère que voilà c'est ce qui compte
c'est l'individu l'hyper individu et que
c'est c'est lui qui doit s'épanouir la
loi n'a plus de sens si vous voulez et
donc le sens de l'intérêt général
disparaît allez je vous laisse terminer
c'est difficile de reprendre parce que
mon propos justement vous avez une
logique je dis qu'il y avait il y a une
différence entre l'autorité et
l'autoritarisme il faut un cadre pour
que la vie sociale puisse se dérouler
pour que le professeur puisse faire
court etc
mais
l'autoritarisme c'est différent c'est
une volonté de dominer et de réduire à
la soumission et ça ce n'est pas
émancipateur et l'objectif quand même de
notre société ça doit être de créer de
former des êtres qui soient libres dotés
d'un esprit critique autonome
responsable et ce que j'entends dans la
bouche de Nicolas Sarkozy de tout un tas
de responsables politiques de droites et
d'extrême droite c'est qu'ils ont une
vision de l'autorité qui est
autoritariste et une définition du
pouvoir qu'il l'est aussi vous citiez un
philosophe en entrée vous référiez à
Platon notamment Anna rent avait
effectivement donné une définition du
pouvoir que je trouve profondément
féministe où elle disait le pouvoir ça
dépend l'exercice d'une domination qui
écrase c'est un pouvoir d'agir ensemble
c'était très capable de faire
de faire que les hommes agissent
collectivement et être un leader puisque
Nicolas Sarkozy dit oui la France manque
d'un leader de verticalité un leader ce
n'est pas quelqu'un qui écrase son
peuple c'est quelqu'un qui est capable
d'inspirer de créer du collectif cette
citation encore une fois excusez-moi de
vous avoir interrompu en pleine
démonstration j'essaye de l'éviter mais
là je trouvais que c'était intéressant
de créer ce ping-pong bref vous parlez
de Nicolas Sarkozy on a on a ressorti
quelques citations effectivement de
cette interview qui était face à
plusieurs lecteurs de nos confrères du
Parisien Aujourd'hui en France justement
sur cette notion de verticalité il nous
dit j'observe avec tristesse la remise
en cause systématique du mot autorité du
mot verticalité qui laisse à penser que
tout le monde n'a que des droits et
aucun devoir je me concentre sur le mot
verticalité parce qu'elle brutner c'est
vrai qu'on est dans une société où la
verticalité du société pyramidale elle
est quand même remise en question un peu
à tous les niveaux et je pourrais
rajouter à la liste des figures
d'autorité le médecin avec des patients
qui arrivent en persuadé que ils savent
déjà tout sur leur propre maladie
c'est quoi votre analyse de cette
période particulière ou cette
verticalité notamment grâce aux réseaux
sociaux elle a pris le pas sur le sur
l'horizontalité a pris le pas sur la
verticalité oui parce que chacun croit
avoir une compétence propre et en tant
que citoyen être légitimé à parler à
s'exprimer puisqu'il est un morceau du
peuple mais alors ce qui a changé c'est
après la guerre la France gaulienne qui
était une France verticale et encore
très archaïque a été bousculé par mai 68
qui a été le la fin des 3P le père le
patron patriarche dont on vit encore les
conséquences aujourd'hui et alors ça a
eu une notamment comme influence dans
l'éducation le fait que la l'autorité
parentale a été partagée à partir de 70
par le père et la mère c'est une petite
loi mais c'est une loi fondamentale on
se rend pas compte que ça a bousculé les
les données anthropologiques et alors
les ma générations
a été la matière d'éducation en général
très libérale et je dirais même trop
libéral puisque nous pensions que toute
loi tout ordre était injuste et que par
conséquent le seul le seul slogan que
nous devions appliquer pour nos enfants
c'est fait ce qu'il te plaît on sera pas
compte qu'un gosse garçon ou fille a
besoin d'être encadré et ça donnait une
génération de jeunes qui est qui était
perdu et qui ce qui se sont cherchés
ensuite des règles ailleurs et puis ça a
débouché sur un phénomène qui est
intéressant qui est le phénomène de
l'enfant roi c'est-à-dire l'enfant sa
majesté de bébé comme disait Freud celui
qui a tous les droits et qui tiranise
ses parents donc on revient un peu à la
citation de de Nicolas Sarkozy qui qui
est un peu à Fourtou philosophique et
donc le donc ça n'est pas la solution
non plus entre le les parents
autoritaires qui giflaient leurs enfants
puisque moi c'est l'éducation que j'ai
eue et c'était la norme à l'époque et on
ne se plaignait pas on essayait de
passer entre les gouttes et l'éducation
ultralib on abandonne toute initiative
au petit il y a peut-être un moyen terme
mais c'est peut-être ça non pas la
réinvention d'autorité mais la
réinvention d'éducation d'ailleurs en
général quand on dit il y a père
d'autorité on dit il y a père
d'éducation il y a pire des verticalité
le discours conservateur c'est un
discours de la perte globale mais à
partir du moment où on sait que ça a
toujours existé c'est qu'il y a sans
doute des solutions moins dramatiques
que celle énoncé par nos leaders
politiques qui sont évidemment toujours
dans la visée d'une prochaine élection
moi je vois ça aussi dans les
entreprises par exemple avec le
télétravail on a des managers qui sont
complètement déboussolés parce que ils
savent pas comment gérer ses employés
qui sont lâchés dans la nature de à
trois jours par semaine et ils savent
pas comment justement dérouler cette
autorité parce que c'est plus la même
donne qu'on va on va plus être je vais
regarder ce que tu fais chaque minute je
vais t'avoir sous la main je vais te
faire faire ci ou quoi ils font inventer
ce nouveau cadre qui fait que peut-être
le l'employé travaille avec des
objectifs et pas forcément à la durée et
c'est la même chose il me semble que ce
qu'on a on aurait envie de l'autorité
c'est-à-dire un cadre mais qui repose
pas sur l'ancien schéma dont vous avez
parlé très bien et qui est vraiment
complètement has been et en effet pas
l'extrême inverse de la totale liberté
qui fait qu'on devient fou et qu'on se
bat les uns et les autres et qu'on
devient complètement individualiste et
là on fait plus sociétés alors les
différences c'est que la famille en
principe moderne et fondée sur l'amour
donc les parents et les enfants sont
censés s'aimer au moins un minimum dans
l'entreprise c'est pas l'amour c'est
l'intérêt il s'aller même l'affectif
donc
là on pourra peut-être parler tout à
l'heure de Macron mais on n'a pas envie
que le PDG en brasse avec effusion ses
employés et d'ailleurs il serait très
choqué s'il le faisait j'espère bien le
Emmanuel Macron tient justement on va
écouter l'une parce que alors on l'a vu
dans nos titres je sais pas si vous
étiez déjà présent dans l'émission tout
à l'heure mais on a fait une sorte de de
patchwork de déclaration de de ministre
du gouvernement avec ce mot autorité
décritée déclinés pardon sous toutes ses
formes évidemment tout ça fait suite aux
émeutes il y a deux mois Emmanuel Macron
on est le 24 juillet on a choisi cet
extrait il est en duplex de Nouméa et il
intervient dans dans les JT de TF1 et de
France 2 après le remaniement et il fait
référence aux émeutes du début de l'été
on l'écoute
la leçon que j'en tire c'est un l'ordre
l'ordre l'ordre la deuxième c'est que
notre pays a besoin d'un retour de
l'autorité à chaque niveau et d'abord
dans la famille
et donc c'est tout le chantier que je
veux pouvoir ouvrir à la fin de l'été
celui de l'autorité parentale c'est que
beaucoup de ces jeunes c'est pas
l'éducation nationale c'est encore moins
la police qui peut régler le problème le
traité à la cause
et donc on doit responsabiliser
certaines familles on doit aussi
accompagner d'autres familles qui sont
dans la détresse et on doit réinvestir
massivement sur notre jeunesse pour lui
redonner un cadre c'est l'autorité à
l'école l'autorité des savoirs
fondamentaux et des maîtres c'est
l'autorité des élus de nos forces de
sécurité
voilà pour cette extrait de la
déclaration d'Emmanuel Macron donc là on
est le 24 juillet il y a eu toute une
sémantique on l'a dit autour de ces
notions d'autorité et d'ordre Émilie
zappalski est-ce qu'on en reste un peu
au stade de l'incantation
et on a toujours pas d'actes donc il y a
véritablement un risque effet
de contre-productif de la force de
répéter l'ordre de l'ordre l'autorité
qui n'est pas des actes derrière et
globalement il risque d'y avoir cette
parole politique décrédibilisée
finalement et l'opposition s'en est
saisie Marine Le Pen récemment elle a
fait sa rentrée politique et elle a tout
de suite remarqué quelque chose le
contraste entre CD discours du
gouvernement et l'effet la réalité des
faits en matière d'autorité notamment un
exemple elle a critiqué l'interdiction
de la Baïa à l'école qui a été mise en
place par le nouveau ministre de
l'éducation nationale Gabriel Attal et
pourquoi et bien la patronne du groupe
des députés rassemblements national elle
estime que cette mesure elle aurait dû
déjà être appliquée avec la loi de 2004
sur les signes rel que finalement il y
avait pas besoin de rajouter une
interdiction en gros pour elle l'état
multiplie les interdictions et pourquoi
simplement parce qu'il n'arrive pas à
faire appliquer ces lois par manque
d'autorité un autre exemple on a la même
chose sur les
occultés vous savez les fameuses
obligations de quitter le territoire
français qu'il est impossible de faire
respecter sans parler aussi des
résultats en matière de délinquance qui
malgré la multiplication des lois
déréglementations et bien ça ne cesse
d'augmenter le bilan 2022 n'est pas bon
du tout donc tout cela finalement c'est
du grain à moudre pour le parti
d'extrême droite qui lui à l'avantage de
pouvoir toujours continuer à parler
parler autorités sans mettre en face des
actes puisque justement lui il est pas
au pouvoir alors on a commencé à
l'évoquer risque de confondre autorité
et autoritarisme oui et c'est parfois
mauvais réflexe qu'on a vu avec le
gouvernement surtout quand il n'arrive
pas ou plus à faire face à la violence
et à la colère notamment de la
population dans ce style on a eu
l'utilisation vous en souvenez sûrement
des procédures juridiques bien sûr tout
à fait légales mais qui était quand même
multiple dans le cadre de l'adoption de
la réforme des retraites 44.2 49-3 enfin
pas toutes les refaire c'est une
utilisation combinée dont le caractère
inhabituel avait même été mis en avant
par le Conseil constitutionnel mais il y
a pas que ça il y a des pratiques aussi
un petit peu musclées ou en tout cas
discutables avec des audio et des et des
sons des vidéos et des audios qui nous
ont été donnés sur les pratiques de
certaines brigades pendant des
manifestations notamment sur cette
réforme des retraites mais pas seulement
il y a eu aussi un petit peu ce type de
débordement durant le mouvement des
gilets jaunes je pense que vous en
souvenez et cette excès d'autoritarisme
c'est aussi exprimé avec l'interdiction
de certaines manifestations réforme des
retraites toujours et même
l'interdiction de certains objets vous
souvenez les casseroles
ça donnait lieu à des déplacements quand
même assez UBS qu'un d'Emmanuel Macron
est de séministres digne d'un film de
Jacques Tati parce qu'on avait d'un côté
les manifestants qui étaient parqués par
la police pour les encadrait bien et
puis de l'autre côté quelques figurants
qui étaient bien choisis pour pour faire
la claque alors sans parler aussi de la
ressentie de Carlo olive le député des
Yvelines vous l'avez cité tout à l'heure
dans le reportage il y avait quelques
sifflets pendant le stade de France
l'ouverture de la Coupe du monde de
rugby quand Emmanuel Macron voilà a
commencé à parler bien le député
Renaissance a eu cette idée folle de
vouloir interdire les manifestations et
les préavis de grève lors des grands
événements comme les Jeux Olympiques
2024 bien sûr c'est une idée qui était
comme ça lancée radio bref dans ce
domaine quand même assez difficile de
l'autorité moi j'aurais un petit conseil
mais ça vient d'une communicante aussi à
la base c'est peut-être un petit peu par
les moins et peut-être d'agir un peu
plus pour être crédible merci et Emilie
tiens sur ce c'est cette image de d'un
Emmanuel Macron sifflé euh par une
partie du du stade Chloé regarde moi je
vais vous dire comment j'ai réagi ça m'a
choqué parce que je me suis c'est pas le
lieu c'est pas le moment c'est voilà
c'est une coupe du monde pourquoi les
les questions franco-françaises il
ferait éruption dans un moment comme
celui-là et vous je comprends que vous
ayez été chagriné que la politique
s'invite dans un moment sportif mais à
ce moment-là vous pouvez aussi
vous questionner sur l'opportunité que
Emmanuel Macron s'exprime à la tribune
s'il n'avait pas fait de discours il
n'aurait pas été ça se passe toujours
comme ça le président ou le chef d'État
du pays du pays qui accueille une grande
compétition c'est un petit discours il
s'expose à partir du moment où il fait
ça et la démocratie elle existe aussi
dans le stade et si les personnes ont
décidé de le siffler parce qu'ils
s'opposent à sa politique c'est leur
droit je crois parce qu'elle va tenir la
le évidemment chef de l'État c'est la
figure suprême de l'autorité dans un
dans un pays comme comme le nôtre ça
vous a choqué qu'il soit sifflet à
l'occasion pas du tout non
l'esprit français
et puis il a plutôt bien réagi parce que
Macron a beaucoup de défauts il a un
certain sang-froid et il a retourné la
foule en fait ça c'est le rêve de tout
homme politique c'est de passer de la
durée aux applaudissements et ça m'a
rappelé une scène que les les jeunes
spectateurs ne connaissent plus c'est
quand Nicolas chez auchescu le 24
décembre 1989 revenant d'Iran
monte au balcon pour s'adresser à ses
partisans ils sont 100 000 personnes il
est sifflé et il part ce qui était autre
chose dans la Roumanie de l'époque et là
et 24 heures après il est fusillé après
après un procès stalinien comme un
malpropre alors ça n'est pas le cas nous
sommes en démocratie dieu merci ça n'est
pas le cas et là Macron a réagi plutôt
bien avec un certain flegme les foules
sont versatides faut se dire ça aussi
c'est les mêmes gens qui ont voté pour
vous vous renverront ensuite
loin de loin de vos de vos appartements
se souvenir qu'après la guerre et de
Gaulle et Churchill grand vainqueur ont
été remerciés par les peuples anglais et
français dans la déclaration d'Emmanuel
Macron qu'on a écouté tout à l'heure il
y avait donc cette je voudrais qu'on
parle d'autorité parentale maintenant il
y avait cette référence à l'autorité
parentale c'est le chantier que je vais
pouvoir ouvrir la fin de l'été celui de
l'autorité parentale Yanis roder est-ce
que qu'est-ce que les politiques peuvent
faire pour restaurer l'autorité
parentale vous voyez ce que je veux dire
un sacré défi c'est une excellente
question parce que effectivement comment
faire pour que les enfants à l'intérieur
des foyers puisque c'est de ça dans nos
parlons comprennent que et bien il a des
règles et que ces règles il faut les
suivre et que ces règles elles nous
structurent en fait elles nous structure
dans la famille et au-delà de la famille
elle nous apprennent justement comment
fonctionne une société et s'il y a des
familles qui dysfonctionnent parfois
cela arrive peut-être faut-il
s'interroger sur les raisons ces
dysfonctionnements les familles
monoparentales
les mamans qui travaillent qui
travaillent la nuit les difficultés
sociales il y a cela personne ne peut
les nier c'est évident mais il n'y a pas
que ça non parce qu'il y a aussi
beaucoup de mamans de familles
parentales qui réussissent à donner un
cadre à leurs enfants tout à fait dans
les enfants réussissent à suivre des
études et à progresser enfin vous voyez
ce que je veux dire faire insultes aux
parents qui qui s'en sortent de de dire
que moi je pense que je pense qu'il faut
il faut il s'agit pas de faire ses
incantations en disant on va rétablir
l'ordre dans les familles sans prendre
en compte la réalité sociale de ce que
c'est pas bien sûr les difficultés c'est
ça que que je voulais dire après après
effectivement il y a aussi des parents
qui sont qui auraient effectivement
besoin d'être supporté d'être aidé
l'école vous savez l'école et notamment
l'école maternelle Les les maîtres des
écoles voient très vite un enfant qui
qui est perturbé parce qu'il peut se
passer à la maison parce que ça se voit
en classe est-ce qu'on a les moyens
aujourd'hui que 1 les enseignants
repèrent cela
face appel au service sociaux à des
psychologues à des orthophonistes est-ce
qu'on a les moyens non on n'a pas les
moyens vous savez moi à Saint-Denis pour
que mes élèves aient accès à une
orthophoniste il faut plus d'un an
d'attente donc on a des difficultés
l'étape pourrait aider les collectivités
locales pourraient aider il y a
peut-être des choses à réfléchir de ce
côté-là comment on pourrait venir en
aide aux familles qui en ont besoin que
retail le dédoublement des des classes
de CP dans les quartiers les éducation
prioritaires c'était une bonne idée une
bonne mesure en la matière si on cherche
des exemples de
d'action politique qui peuvent permettre
finalement d'aider des parents ou de ou
de restaurer l'autorité parentale je
sais pas si c'est quelque chose qui aide
les parents en tout cas ça aide les
enfants le dédoublement la réduction du
nombre d'élèves par classe c'est quelque
chose que nous demandons très fortement
mais moi je trouve que c'est quand même
sur cette question de l'autorité
parentale très violent de s'en prendre à
ces familles le plus souvent
défavorisées ou ces familles parental
qui n'ont pas eu la chance ces enfants
là comme Emmanuel Macron de grandir dans
un cadre favorisé très structuré où on
part en vacances ou je ne sais quoi donc
franchement cette réponse uniquement en
martelant l'ordre et le besoin
d'autorité parentale paraît d'une
violence totale et d'une inefficacité
inouïe parce que il n'y aura pas d'ordre
durable sans justice et ça nous le
disons nous le disons très très
fortement donc il faut répondre aux
problèmes de ces quartiers les
déghettoïsé parce que ce sont des
ghettos scolaires
économiques
et puis aussi il faut adresser le
problème de la relation nocive entre les
jeunes des quartiers populaires et la
police ce que le président de la
République
ignore totalement alors que cette
relation elle empire depuis 40 ans et
engendre des violences qui sont réelles
sur ce thème de la police je vous
propose d'écouter tout de suite une
réaction du ministre de l'intérieur on
est au cœur de l'été on est le 11 août
dernier Gérald Darmanin s'adresse à des
jeunes diplômés de l'académie de police
à Périgueux et alors lui aussi par
autorité et autoritarisme écoutons
être policier c'est imposé l'ordre sans
autoritarisme
c'est être convaincu de la force
tranquille de la République
celle qui s'impose sans excès
sans excitation sans débordement
mais tout naturellement
car gardien de la paix l'autorité est
naturelle elle n'a pas besoin de cris
pas besoin d'insultes
pas besoin de tutoiement
elle s'impose
[Musique]
même face à la peur et vous aurez peur
même face au stress et vous serez
stressé
même face à la mort
et elle jouera avec vous
l'autorité naturelle des policiers la
force tranquille de la de la République
Pascal Bruckner est-ce que c'est un un
monde idéal ou une France du passé à
laquelle fait référence Gérald Darmanin
quand il dit ça ah oui c'est une police
qui n'existait nulle part qui n'existera
jamais il y a vraiment une ambivalence
dans notre attitude vis-à-vis de la
police nous avons besoin d'elle pour
nous protéger nous la détestons tous
parce que quand elles viennent nous
importuner nous arrêter ou nous mettre
des amendes et donc ce que dit Gérald
Darmanin est évidemment très difficile
quand un policier se fait traiter de
tous les noms et on le voit dans la rue
insulter on lui crache dessus il est
très difficile de se conduire comme un
philosophe des Lumières avec la
bienveillance et le flegme d'un Bobby
britannique il y a un moment ce sont des
hommes ou des femmes ils ont peur comme
la comme l'a dit Darmanin il a eu raison
de dire vous serez insulté vous serez
menacé de mort et à certains moments il
faut encadrement extrêmement fort pour
ne pas céder à la violence or la la
police n'a le droit que d'exercer la
violence légitime dès que l'autre passe
ce droit elle verse dans l'arbitraire
c'est un métier impossible c'est un
métier absolument impossible et pourtant
indispensable et donc
je comprends que ça que ça passionne une
partie de la population mais à part être
commissaire de police ou enquêteur je ne
vois pas qui a envie d'aller prendre des
coups des pavés et de se faire cracher
dessus par des jeunes gens un peu
remontés pour être dans le féminisme on
sait pas trop qui on entend quand on
entend Gérald darmanino est-ce que c'est
le ministre de l'intérieur ou est-ce que
c'est un futur candidat parce que
c'était dans le cadre de son de sa
rentrée un petit peu politique il me
semble ou pas c'était
le 11 août devant des élèves
de cette nouvelle en tout cas posture
que souhaite Gérald Darmanin puisqu'il a
pas été premier ministre un peu de
frustration c'est juste parce que c'est
pas forcément
avec vous mais pourquoi pas
des manifestations par exemple non je
parlais il y a eu vraiment des pratiques
différentes et des façons de d'ordonner
les choses différemment qui ont donné
des résultats à différents parfois on
avait l'impression que c'était bien
encadré justement bien préparé qu'on
fouiller les gens avant qu'ils arrivent
et qu'on les Nasser pas au milieu des
places d'Italie par exemple pour qu'ils
s'entrechoquent tous et que finalement
parfois des bonnes pratiques amènent des
bons comportements et on entend beaucoup
d'élus un beaucoup de mères qui
réclament justement le retour de la
police de proximité pour justement créer
aussi du lien avec ces jeunes même si ça
paraît impossible aujourd'hui dans leur
tête ça existait ça ça peut exister
parfois on va en parler de la figure de
l'élu et du maire dans un très court
instant avec avec alexandre Poussin mais
je reste sur cette question de la police
et
est-ce que on va employer le terme de
respectabilité et je vous donnerai la
porte juste après mais est-ce que vous
faites le lien entre et je fais aucun
amalgame entre certains jeunes qui
peuvent être réfractaires à l'autorité
du professeur est-ce que ce sont pour
vous les mêmes que ceux qui vont être
référentaires à l'autorité policière
voir vont participer à des émeutes
est-ce que vous faites ce lien là où
est-ce que c'est trop binaire pas
nécessairement néanmoins il est évident
que on a des jeunes quelques-uns
peut-être plus que quelques-uns
qui ne comprennent pas ce de quoi relève
l'autorité si vous voulez à quoi
qu'est-ce que c'est que l'autorité et en
fait parce que ils sont dans une espèce
de toute puissance et je me souviens
parfaitement de cet élève
policière sur l'autorité policière quand
on dit de quelqu'un qu'il fait autorité
ça veut dire que cette personne est
respectée
et pour être respecté il faut être
respectable il y a une majorité de
Français qui respecte sa police sa
gendarmerie mais pour une minorité ça
n'est pas le cas et ça doit nous
interroger parce que nous savons que ces
dernières années il y a eu des violences
policières constater pendant les gilets
jaunes des nacent des bombes black
crimaux
arbitraire des tirs de LBD arbitraire là
pendant les émeutes encore des cas de
violences documentées sur des jeunes des
quartiers qui ne représentaient pas de
menaces etc etc et il y a ces violences
là qui sont commises dans des moments de
haute tension j'en conviens mais le
problème c'est que ces violences là sont
cautionnées par la hiérarchie policière
qui se tient toujours du côté des
syndicats compris très agressif
qui soutiennent les policiers auteurs de
ces violences disproportionnées donc il
faut si vous voulez quand même là aussi
faire preuve d'autorité vis-à-vis de
ceux qui nuisent à la respectabilité de
la police parce que on ne peut pas être
respecté si on n'est pas respectable
allez on va parler des élus nous reste
quelques minutes ce débat passe beaucoup
trop vite ça veut dire qu'il est
passionnant mais on va parler des élus
et je propose Alexandre Poussard de nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau tout de suite
bonsoir Alexandre le Parlement le
gouvernement qui essaye de prendre un
certain nombre de mesures face à la à
cette recrudescence de violence envers
les élus ah oui car on se souvient cette
année de l'incendie de la maison du
maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses victimes et
bien de cette incendie pendant les
émeutes ou encore de l'incendie du
domicile de mer du maire de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins cet hiver le maire
qui suite à ce incendie avait décidé de
démissionner alors face à cette hausse
de violence contre les élus et bien
gouvernement a annoncé de nouvelles
mesures d'abord un pack sécurité avec la
création de postes de référent atteinte
aux élus dans les commissariats dans les
gendarmeries pour mieux recueillir la
parole des élus victimes de violence un
système d'alarme ça veut dire que dès
qu'un élu est victime de pression de
violence est bien quand il fait le 17 un
dispositif de sécurité est mise en place
ou encore une stratégie une menace une
évaluation c'est pour analyser plus
finement les menaces qui pèsent contre
les élus locaux et puis le gouvernement
va reprendre une mesure qui a été votée
par le Sénat l'an dernier et c'est tout
simplement un durcissement de la peine
encourue pour l'auteur de violence
contre un élu pour la porter à 50
prisons et 75000 euros d'amende c'est à
dire l'aligner au niveau de la peine
encourue pour un auteur de violence
contre un policier ou un pompier alors
c'est une mesure qui a été retoquée pour
des raisons techniques par le Conseil
constitutionnel mais qui va être
réintégré par le gouvernement dans un
autre texte et malheureusement c'est
violent contre les élus elles sont pas
nouvelles mais oui rappelez-vous en des
l'année 2019 et bien le maire de signe
dans le département du Var Jean Mathieu
Michel avait été
passer par une camionnette il était
décédé après être intervenu contre un
dépôt de gravats sauvage et suite à ce
drame et bien le Sénat avait lancé une
consultation des maires sur les
violences faites aux élus et le résultat
de cette consultation c'est que déjà 92%
des maires déclarés avoir déjà fait
l'objet de violence verbale ou de
violence physique alors à l'époque les
sénateurs et le gouvernement c'était
déjà mis d'accord sur des mesures de
protection notamment dans la loi
engagement et proximité c'était en 2019
un texte qui renforçait le pouvoir de
police du maire pour qu'il puisse
davantage donner de sanctions
administratives ce texte a créé
également et bien une protection
fonctionnelle des maires c'est à dire un
système d'assurance qui est financé par
la collectivité et puis autre avancée
législative en date c'était en 2022 en
une loi proposée par la sénatrice
Nathalie Delattre qui permettait aux
associations des lieux et bien de se
constituer partie civile en cas
d'agression d'un élu dans le cadre de
ses fonctions merci beaucoup alexandre
Poussin Pascal Bruckner le maire c'est
devenu le quoi le symbole le plus proche
de l'état pour un certain nombre de
d'administrer de citoyens c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont à ce point pris pour cible
on cherche à responsable assez malheurs
quel qu'il soit des malheurs domestiques
professionnelles ou autres et donc on
s'attaque à la figure de l'autorité et
ce qui caractérise les maires et les
élus c'est qui n'ont aucune autorité
c'est qu'ils sont faibles ces personnes
privées physiques et ça ça signale quand
même enfin ça dit quand même beaucoup
d'un certain délitement on ne peut pas
on ne peut pas nier et que malgré tout
les rapports entre citoyens en France et
spécialement à Paris monte très vite aux
extrêmes les insultes les injures qu'on
voyait des collisions et des accidents
et des gens qui commencent à se taper
dessus on se dit oui c'est quand même un
vrai problème et je ne sais pas c'est un
problème d'autorité mais c'est un
problème de civilité la politesse paraît
une une notion alors antédilie Vienne et
c'est difficile de régler les conflits
c'est plus difficile de réinstaurer une
forme d'autorité dans une société
fracturée est-ce que vous évidemment
d'autant que d'autant que Emmanuel
Macron est une figure d'autorité floue
n'oubliez pas qu'il a quand même été élu
sur la séduction
l'amour du pouvoir chez lui a commencé
par le pouvoir de l'amour il voulait
qu'on l'aime il voulait qu'on l'adule il
avait il était comme une rockstar dans
les stades et il semble avoir du mal à
instaurer avec citoyens autre chose
qu'un rapport de est-ce que je vous
plaît est-ce que vous m'aimez est-ce que
vous je peux vous faire les yeux doux
c'est pas le problème de Poutine c'est
pas le problème ici jimping d'ailleurs
dans la gestuelle macronienne vous
verrez qu'avec certains avec
Zena ski c'était les embrassades il est
tout foires
zanas qui était gêné regardez ailleurs
mais avec Poutine et c'est une fille que
ça marche pas du tout ni avec des autres
la lumière Poutine souvenez-vous il
avait mis une table de 12 mètres
on regarde ça les Français regardent ça
ils se dit mais qu'est ce leader est-ce
qu'il est vraiment un leader ou est-ce
qu'il veut simplement est-ce qu'il a
besoin de notre affection que nous
sommes prêts à lui donner à condition
qu'il y ait des résultats mais est-ce
que c'est pas notre paradoxe
ultime Chloé Ridel la description
d'Emmanuel Macron vous avez évidemment
beaucoup fais sourire de Pascal Bruckner
mais à la fois c'est un peu le
fonctionnement de notre cinquième
république avec ce monarque républicain
donc on élit un monarque républicain et
en même temps on veut continuer de nous
couper la tête jour après jour non mais
vous savez que nous y sommes très
opposés à ce fonctionnement et vous
parler des violences contre les élus moi
je pense que ce que cela signale c'est
une crise démocratique quand on a
recours à la violence contre des élus
c'est parce qu'on ne peut pas si vous
voulez c'est parce que le système
démocratique ne suffit plus à réguler le
conflit ça sert à ça la démocratie ça
sert à réguler la violence au sein d'une
société et pour ça il faut qu'elle
puisse fonctionner quand on a un
président qui effectivement
se coupe pendant notamment la réforme
des retraites si on peut parler de ça
passe en force contre sa majorité au
Parlement est obligée d'avoir recours
aux 49,3 passe en force contre majorité
de son peuple qui défile dans la rue
vous voyez bien que cette forme
autoritaire pour le coup d'exercer le
pouvoir créer de la violence en retour
dans la société et donc la solution à ça
c'est pas de dire ah oui il faut faire
preuve d'autorité contre ceux qui bien
sûr que c'est nécessaire de de punir les
attentes à la loi et les atteintes aux
élus très sévèrement mais si on veut
s'attaquer aux causes il faut aller à la
racine et la racine c'est que nos
institutions démocratiques ne
fonctionnent plus très bien donc on sait
quelles sont les solutions il faut
renforcer le pouvoir du Parlement avoir
plus recours au référendum etc mais il
faut des présidentialiser ce régime
parce que cela crée de la violence un
dernier mot Yanis Robert il y a dans les
dans les idées avancées par Emmanuel
récemment il y a fait de doubler les
heures de on dit plus instruction
civique évidemment
merci beaucoup enseignement moral et
civique bon c'est quoi
c'est une heure par semaine aujourd'hui
une demi-heure bon donc on passera une
heure mais ça sert à quelque chose quand
même cette cette ça dépend comment on
fait c'est comme tout ça comme on le
fait si vous expliquez si vous voulez ce
que c'est qu'une société à partir de
l'histoire et pourquoi nous fonctionnons
comme ça à partir d'une d'une profondeur
historique oui ça peut servir à quelque
chose si je prends l'exemple de la
laïcité d'où vient la laïcité pourquoi
la laïcité bien sûr que si on prend
cette profondeur historique ça va servir
à quelque chose mais si on se sert de
ses heures pour annoner il y a tant de
députés tant de sénateurs ils sont élus
tous les 6 ans bien sûr il faut le faire
mais il faut aller dans le fond des
choses il faut donner du sens à la
société dans laquelle nous vivons merci
beaucoup merci à tous je rappelle le
titre de vos livres parce que le sacre
des pantoufles qui est publié aux
éditions grassées du renoncement au
monde et Yanis Robert la jeunesse esse
française l'école et la République
publié aux éditions de l'Observatoire je
vous dis à demain 18h22 heures pour un
nouveau numéro 2 sens public et notez
que Renault Muselier président du
conseil régional de la région
Provence-Alpes-Côte d'Azur sera l'invité
Dorian Mancini demain 8h dans la
matinale depuis Xena évidemment belle
soirée
[Musique]